Here the solution is 8 plus 7i, and here the solution is 3 plus 7i. Great work
if you figured those two out. We're really adding these two complex numbers
together, so we can drop the parentheses. Next, I want to combine my real parts
and my imaginary parts. I know addition is commutative, so I can rewrite this
line as 2 plus 6 plus 3i plus 4i, 2 plus 6 equals 8 And 3i plus 4i equals 7i.
Remember I represents the square root of negative 1. So we have 3 square roots
of negative 1 and 4 square roots of negative 1. That gives us a total of 7
square roots of negative 1 or just 7i. When we subtract a complex number, we
want to distribute this negative 1 to each of the terms. So we'll have negative
3 plus 2i. Then we combine the real parts of 6 and negative 3 and combine the
imaginary parts of 5i and 2i. This gives us a total of 3 plus 7i. Our final
result.